one thing about this Biden speech was
it's basically the greatest Amtrak n
ever somehow Amtrak like stands for like
good government and like government
helping the people so that I thought was
just a super weird element my biggest
problem Joe Biden tonight and I and I
have a lot of respect for him after
seeing his family hearing about the
personal situation was was was Biden
repeatedly tying everything that's going
wrong in Iraq to the bush administration
exclusively I think the bush
administration deserves a lot of blame
for what's going wrong but what about
the Democrats in Congress what about Joe
Biden in the Senate with a very senior
and responsible position supporting the
bush administration so to talk about the
bush administration's failings failings
the abysmal performance of Bush
administration and no acknowledgement of
his own guilt his own responsibility for
what's gone wrong a track seems to me
that this is this is this is hardly the
kind of changed Obama's been promising
us one other question I think it's
interesting on the the Biden's sort of
hammering on the Bush administration my
initial reaction is that this is this is
smart politics this is what you should
do because bush's approval ratings are
like what you know half a percent or you
know- five kelvin or something I mean
it's really you know terrible stuff is
there a point where the average sort of
semi political American says you know
alright are we get and this is like
seems it seems like piling on at this
point I think it's now clear why they
chose by right he's uh it's this nice
grandfatherly figure right they're
emphasizing that by bringing out the 37
blonde children and he is going to be
out there nice grandpa guys got this
great story he's got a brain aneurysm
he's got dead wife is fantastic stuff
but he's just gonna rip john mccain
strode out every day all day that's what
I got
you